[Music]
look I know this season didn't go as
planned it's known as the beautiful game
but let's face it it's a complicated
game guys football soccer as you like to
call
it is like life you know you're riding
high in April and shot down in
May um next season I think we have a
real shot as long as you uh trust me and
allow me to play the system that I like
to
play I'm sorry uh Thomas did nobody tell
you you're you're
fired did did honestly nobody tell you
Reese did you not of course I I'm fired
are you joking are you kidding me
obviously you're in shock which is
understandable and it's only natural
that you go through the five stages of
grief which Reese I think you have a yes
thank you Alex we'll just quickly run
this meazy thank you Chris there we go
yep too far release it no you've lost it
settle it there just yep there we go
thanks Chris spin it
round no you you got to flip it flip
this y there we go and spin it
round stage one denial this is not
happening there it is that's it that's
classic denial good news is you got two
options reys option one that's where
you're currently at or
Chris the Pacific Ocean uh would yes uh
but no specifically American SAR
American Samoa are you serious is this a
joke Gale do you know about this yes it
was my
idea can't believe you do this to
me I deserve some respect boy I'm the
only one in this room that knows
anything about this game stage
two anger that anger is real was he this
angry when you were married he was
calmer before Thomas you need to stop
thinking about this as some kind of
punishment this could be a chance to
heal maybe find a new direction oh Gil I
love that Gil that is so good excellent
I played this game at the top
level this isn't fair
fair you want to know about
Fair well here we go let me tell you a
story buddy when I was a kid I had this
dog and I love this dog but then he got
older I guess he had some anger issues
wasn't the same dog my dad said that we
needed to put the dog down so we take
him outside and this dog he is
whimpering we taking him out oh no this
isn't fair remember how good I was in
the past and my dad made me take that
dog
outside and drown him in the
pond I'm the dog in this story no of
course not I'm just telling you a story
about my dog when I was growing up and
the fact that my dad was a bit of
an okay
look I can change I'm flexible guys
let's not make any rash decisions here
really really good stuff Thomas you are
smoking through these so I need two lift
oh that's great so I got
a wow
Chris we only got one left and it's my
favorite one of
all Pacific
oan Pacific
oan
,000 miles
[Music]
wide Pacific
o Pacific
o
Pacific 90,000
mde Pacific
oan Pacific
oan Mr Mr hello Mr ran welcome to
American Sam what is this no naughty
words pretty please this is who's on the
plane American Sam's toprated show we
interview people who travel to the
island on the plane so I guess what
everyone at home wants to know is why
have you come halfway across the world
to coach the worst soccer team in the
world I have a very particular set of
skills skills I've acquired over a very
long career skills that make me a night
M for people like
you I've come here to impass my
knowledge and unique insight into the
beautiful game and turn this team around
I'm not
God but I may as well be because I
perform more miracles than
him okay well one thing is for sure the
new coach is very friendly and outgoing
we'll see you next time for another
edition of who's on the
plane Mr Thomas
oh it's very nice to meet you I'm toita
I'm the president of the Football
Federation of American sore and also the
cameraman for who's on the plane it's a
small island we all have lots of jobs
now as an honored guest we have a very
special surprise waiting outside okay so
gu we look after you yeah you love
this this is so exciting guys guys why
are we here so part of my exciting
Master surprise plan gentlemen I am
proud to to officially announce a new
official national coach of the American
sour soccer team
oh played with some of the top players
in the
world and he's originally from
Europe so let's give him a warm American
sour welcome um okay
guys
your chariot
[Music]
awaits yeah okay
okay yeah great stuff guys I think it
feels really welcome we see you at
training Hey Dad how many offsh show
people apply for their job oh the resp
was incredible yeah how many people
responded well it was him yeah it was
just him but the fact that he responded
absolutely incredible I really think
things are going to turn around you know
son it's like in The Matrix I think this
man is the
Neo welcome to American sore with a
population of
57,5 34 people American sore is a United
States Territory like Puerto Rico but
much smaller and further away the two
main exports are NFL players and tuna
they should not be confused with the
independent nation of sore with their
cocky stuck up people always bragging
about the 24-hour McDonald's even though
we are both s there are two s War we
drive faster oh I I would never break
the speed limit it's 20 mph across the
whole island interesting fact the bird
on the frag of American
St welcome to your new
accommodation oh that's your car so you
can move around the island at
will and now the PS the
residance Your Castle
awaits your landlord is C he lives in
the house next door and he's available
724 to address your every need 724 7
days out of every
24 well I'll let you get settled in and
I'll leave this welcome to American s
more video here for you to Peru set you
Alicia the qualifiers are only four
weeks away Mr rongan all I won from our
team is just one
goal one
goal one goal
[Music]